How come my oncologist doesn't run tumor marker tests as a standard protocol?
Good question. I think they should. But I think I could only guess, but I think they don't run
tumor marker tests because they're assuming that you're going to do it, they're telling you to do.
Which is typically, if you're going to win oncologists, you have cancer, and typically they're
going to recommend chemotherapy. If you're running tumor marker tests and you do chemotherapy,
and you run those tumor marker tests again, when you're doing chemotherapy or shortly thereafter,
typically you're going to have an elevation of those tumor markers, even though there's
die-off of the cancer, because tumor markers are proteins. They're blood markers that are proteins
that certain cells can give off. Even if you don't have cancer, you're tumor markers are
going to be zero because all cells that are metabolizing can give off these proteins. So
your tumor markers will never be zero even if you don't have cancer. So even somebody without
prostate cancer can still have a PSA of two or four, and that's still within normal range.
Well, why if it doesn't have cancer, it's still giving off that tumor marker because it's a protein
that is given off by normal cells also. But if the cell is rapidly replicated, they have the ability
to give off those more cells, or if a cancer that is dying and being destroyed can spill those.
So if a person is doing chemotherapy, it can spill more tumor marker chemicals, those enzymes,
those proteins, and then it will read higher. And then the person will freak out, why do I do
this chemotherapy? I see a 1999 went up during the middle of my chemotherapy and the doctor has
to explain, no, no, no, it's just because the cancer cells are dying, and it's spilling out this,
and now it's reading higher, and then the patients confused, and the patients, man,
and I'm sad that you have to talk this person off the cliff. That's my, I can be totally wrong,
but that's my theory on why they don't do, because they can be very beneficial in giving a person
an idea of, if their care is going well, except if you're doing chemotherapy. So if you're doing
chemotherapy, don't run a tumor marker panel. It's worthless. If you stopped chemotherapy
four months ago, and now you want to run it, then that's fine, but you kind of got to start with a new
baseline. So that's the only thing. If you're doing chemotherapy, tumor markers are kind of dull and
void. Not always, but mostly, most of them are going to be dull and void, and I think that's why
a college is are expecting you to do exactly what they tell you. I mean, most people do, and if
that's the case, you're running, you're doing chemotherapy, and that makes two of our first kind of